There are a lot of films that probably come
to mind when you think about superheroes.
The genre covers an insane range of movies,
but a special few definitely stand out above
the rest.
From the Marvel and DC universes to a few
outside-the-box superhero films, these are
the best superhero movies you absolutely must
see.
The Avengers
The Marvel Cinematic Universe currently spans
more than a dozen films and counting, but
the pinnacle of the franchise was arguably
established relatively early on with The Avengers.
The studio tapped geek demigod Joss Whedon
to write and direct the project, and the result
was a critical and commercial hit.
The Avengers remains one of the most successful
films ever made.
The movie pulled in more than $1.5 billion
worldwide and is still one of the highest
rated films in the MCU.
It's a comic book brought to life in the best
possible way thanks to Whedon's ability to
blend a bevy of characters and a compelling
story into one perfect package.
The Dark Knight
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy is
widely considered one of the best Batman interpretations
ever put to screen.
It's been more than a decade since the trilogy
launched, so it's easy to forget just how
significant these movies were for the franchise.
Eight years after Batman & Robin bombed, Nolan
proved the Caped Crusader was still viable
on the big screen with Batman Begins...then
raised the stakes even higher with 2008's
The Dark Knight, arguably the best of the
bunch.
The film is moody, smart, atmospheric, and
boasted some of the best superhero action
scenes ever put to film.
Heath Ledger's performance as the Joker is
a particularly fine example of the genre's
dramatic potential.
"Never start with the head the victim gets
all fuzzy you can't feel the…"
"See?"
Captain America: Civil War
This Captain America sequel has been described
as Avengers 2.5, and for good reason.
It featured as many heroes as your typical
Avengers film, and told a politically charged
story that set Earth's Mightiest Heroes against
one another in one of the most eye-popping
big-screen battles ever conceived.
Along with giving fans high-stakes hero vs.
hero battles, Civil War also took a major
step toward moving the MCU forward.
It introduced Chadwick Boseman's Black Panther
to mainstream audiences, and gave us our first
look at Tom Holland's newest incarnation of
Spider-Man.
"I coulda stuck the landing a little better
it's just the new suit.
"Yea yea, we really don't need to.. start
a conversation."
"Ok ok."
"Cap..
Captain."
The Incredibles
We're calling it right here and now: The Incredibles
is one of the best superhero movies ever.
"Honey…"
"What…"
"Where is my super suit?"
"What?"
"Where is my super suit!?"
Brad Bird's 2004 animated masterpiece was
basically a spin on the classic Fantastic
Four story, but with so much more.
It built a fascinating world and seamlessly
grappled with questions of adulthood and responsibility
in ways kids and grown-ups could follow and
appreciate.
It's also crazy fun and laugh-out-loud hilarious.
"Oh."
It's taken almost 15 years, but a sequel is
finally in the works with a release date set
for 2019.
Does The Incredibles need a sequel?
No, but having Brad Bird back in the saddle
helps ease our fears.
A little.
Iron Man
This movie is the granddaddy of the MCU, and
it's just as good today as it was when it
blew our socks off in 2008.
With heavy hitters like the X-Men and Spider-Man
already sold off to larger studios, Marvel
had to pull heroes from the bench to launch
its shared universe.
Iron Man was one of the best of the rest,
so they gave director Jon Favreau a lot of
freedom and banked on the charisma of Robert
Downey, Jr.
The gamble worked, and this movie managed
to tell an extremely fun story while setting
the tone for the dozen or so movies to follow.
It's also a textbook example of how to get
a superhero origin story right on film.
Deadpool
It's an absolute miracle this blood-soaked,
F-bomb-drenched film ever made it out of development
hell, but aren't we all glad it did?
A Deadpool movie kicked around in script form
for years, but it took a leaked concept reel
to finally build enough momentum to get it
made.
The Merc With A Mouth now holds the record
for the highest-grossing X-Men film and the
highest-grossing R-rated film in history.
Not bad for a B-list comic character with
a foul mouth.
"That does it!"
"Oh.. ah ah...Canada!"
X-Men: Days of Future Past
Combining the worlds of the original X-Men
trilogy with the prequel-sequel X-Men: First
Class was a tall order, but Bryan Singer pulled
it off in spades with his return to the franchise.
Days of Future Past managed to deftly weave
together a story spanning decades, with two
separate casts, and still keep all those narrative
threads tight enough that even casual fans
could still follow along.
It also stealthily retconned the disappointing
X-Men: The Last Stand, making all things right
within the cinematic X-universe.
Not bad, right?
Blade 2
When the first Blade film, released in 1998,
turned out to be a surprise box office hit,
the studio brought in Guillermo del Toro to
tackle the sequel.
Blade 2 was basically everything you loved
about the first film, but better.
Instead of just fighting bloodsuckers, day
walker Blade is roped into a larger fight
for survival against the positively terrifying
Reapers.
Much like X-Men, this film was an early proving
ground for serious adaptations of superhero
stories that predated The Avengers and their
pals by several years.
Logan
After the unanticipated mega-success of the
R-rated Deadpool, 2017's Logan finally allowed
Jackman's spirit animal to spill copious amounts
of blood, sever limbs, and make full use of
the colorful vocabulary he's long enjoyed
in the comics.
Pitched as basically "Little Miss Sunshine
with superheroes," Logan is a movie that X-Men
fans never expected to actually happen.
Inspired by the classic Western Shane and
very loosely based on Mark Millar's Old Man
Logan comics, Logan makes Wolverine interesting
again as a broken man with a failing healing
factor.
Sir Patrick Stewart gives one of the best
performances of his career, but it's Dafne
Keen's performance as the merciless X-23 that
elevates a would-be grim character study into
must-see neo-Western murder-pageant.
Guardians of the Galaxy
This movie is just crazy fun.
Chris Pratt's Star-Lord proves that '70s rock
songs belong in outer space—and so do Marvel
superheroes.
Zoe Saldana enchants as the green-skinned
assassin with a conscience, Gamora.
Bradley Cooper shows his impressive range
as the voice of Rocket Raccoon, and Vin Diesel's
Groot makes three words speak volumes.
"I am Groot"
"Yea, that's as fascinating as the first 89
times you told me that."
Sure, Thanos's powers seem limited to interdimensional
conference calls and brooding in his floating
space chair, and Ronan the Accuser's actions
defy common understanding of the Infinity
Stones.
But none of these discrepancies really matter,
because it's just so much fun to watch.
"What are you doing?"
I'm distracting ya, ya big turd blossom."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!